tell us about your characters brother
and sister bond and why that's important
to the film well I think our our
characters the the heart of their story
is it's they're very they're connected
history with each other in their
familial history and their ultimate goal
is to protect each other and then the
next alternate goal is to protect where
they come from sokovia
they're all they have in the world yeah
and and yeah they're these twins that
you know very much sort of Union Yang
they saw you know balance each other and
she's very kind of nurturing and loving
towards him and he has been a very kind
of protective kind of boisterous kind of
way you know sort of supersonic speed
he's very quick tempered and hot-headed
and she's more sort of calmer and
thoughtful and and but them too as a
force kind of really stir some serious
chaos within the Avengers yeah now you
guys both your characters bring powers
to the Cinematic Universe that we've
never really even seen before
subscribe each of your characters powers
and how they're used in the film um I
have the power of telekinesis and I can
also manipulate people's minds and
there's really no blueprint to how
Scarlet Witch would move with her magic
and her powers and how she would
manipulate energy so we would just from
the images from the comics we created a
movement from that and that was really
special and fun and it was really it's
also really nice to be able to play a
character that can have mind control I
think that's really cool even though I
can't actually do anything like that in
Britain every Quicksilver well yeah I
mean it's just like I mean I had to
perfect the skit
you know his the skid in and then
quickly - out thing you know I did do a
lot of the running anyway you know it
just got sped up and then they added you
know blur to it so but it was a lot of
fun you know
you know I trained
sort of in that sort of sprinting kind
of routine of you know workouts kind of
that sort of mentality and physique and
stuff I have to now you guys have had
the opportunity worked with each other
before how did that help you when moving
into Avengers age of Ultron like that
was that was major yeah you know it's
like kind of going on with an hour like
yes stepping onto this set felt like you
know it was gonna be really scary but
everyone was really lovely and wasn't
scary but it makes us have like an
easier report each other as the
characters as well and it wasn't like
hey nice to meet you let's let's figure
out somehow yeah like how intimate we
are like we already know each other
already know how to communicate with
each other kind of speeds up a process
and and we already I like I already feel
safe working with Aaron I feel like I'm
in good hands
so most of us I say yeah yeah very
comforting to go on to say with Lizzy to
talk about your experience and working
with the director like Joss Whedon on
this phone he's incredible yeah so much
to balance like not only like all these
characters but how everything's gonna
look at the end and if to how the story
is tracking and like I mean I don't I
don't understand how he's able to keep
everything connected at all times and
you can ask him any kind of question at
any time and you could be talking about
a scene that's you're filming in a few
days and it's you know everything's
jumbled but he knows exactly what's
going on at all times it's incredible
he's Mia he's genius so I'm really kind
of puppeteering it all together and you
know and sir
the script was incredible how he kind of
manipulated each character you could
really see the voice come off the page
so he's free genius oh yeah you have
both been part of big franchises before
we may be nothing to this scale what
does it been like both in terms of maybe
the pressure that you feel from the fans
and the excitement feel from the fans
and coming onto this film that maybe you
haven't felt in others in your careers
the excitement issues I was watching the
other day I was like damn we're in
another awesome movie like just sort of
slip and landed in this like you know
awesome movies I say cool you know the
pressure I mean that kind of
stuff you is sell out of your control
that your that you just try and do what
you think is right for the character and
what Joss and Kevin Feige you think is
right for the character and you guys
create something together and I don't
think marbles that were steered anyone
wrong so it's it's kind of a nice nice
gang to be a part of
you